my name is Steve Steve Chen probably
most well known for being one of the
cofounders of YouTube and one of the
probably the earliest employees of
PayPal PayPal a Inc and a little known
fact I was also one of the earliest
engineers at Facebook for about three
months before so that was kind of this
in sandwich between PayPal and starting
YouTube I was working at Facebook and so
in 2005 when I was following my taxes I
was filing taxes with both PayPal
Facebook and YouTube on it and I don't
think anybody else can make that claim
ever I think for a while there so I left
YouTube in about 2009 2010 and how
bubbly for the first 12 months there was
trying to figure out this is all
throughout the 20s and even early thirty
it was just working on startups and it
was always the kind of there's no
difference between Monday Wednesday
Saturday Sunday there's no difference
between whatever 9:00 a.m. and 3:00 a.m.
and the morning and so I've been doing
that for over a decade and I was always
thinking throughout that decade while I
was having fun there were all these
other things just starting to get into
coffee and photography and headphones
and just speakers and watching all these
movies that came out throughout all that
time but I never got a chance to watch
but after the first 12 months I just
realized that none of it is as fun as
kind of the the challenge the excitement
the sort of just everything that that
that motivates people to start companies
nothing really compares to that so got
back into starting a company and so
that's what I'm doing now I went back to
Google Google Ventures as an
entrepreneur in residence for about 18
months and got the support from Google
Ventures and then just about a month and
a half ago in August of 2015
left Google Ventures because we were
ready to start getting external funding
and doing our own hiring with the the
the early days of YouTube started in
serve in that 2005 timeframe
I think that the idea the domain name
itself we bought it in on Valentine's
Day so February 14 2005 there was
another co-founder Chad Hurley we were
in Menlo Park California and you can
imagine we search for YouTube on Google
and zero results came up right um and so
we went out bought the domain name
youtube.com and started talking about
the site the site itself originally the
idea was it's a little embarrassing to
talk about but it was actually supposed
to be a kind of a dating site I was
supposed to be supposed to be a dating
site where instead of posting your your
personal pictures and your personal
introduction you would post a video and
that would just a great thing together
you're a little introduction to yourself
but you would actually see this person
and be able to interact with them which
you know we started developing all the
backend was still more or less the same
with what you see with YouTube today
being able to upload videos being able
to transcode videos being able to embed
these videos on two different sites out
there on to social networking sites and
the development that the site took about
three months and we launched it and May
of 2005 and for the first week it was a
total flop you know we didn't get a
single video uploaded that was that was
within the category domain of what we
thought the site was gonna be nobody was
introducing themselves as using the site
as a video dating site however what we
saw was that videos were being uploaded
and so within that first week we quickly
changed again the back end of the site
remained exactly the same
it was just changing you know instead of
searching for male or female in the age
you just search for whatever you want
her to search for in a video and the
look and feel of it could it was changed
a bit but it was a very quick two day
effort to convert what was a sort of a
dating video site into a general video
site and one of the things is Chad I met
Chad the other co-founder at PayPal the
first day I moved out here to California
he was the original
of PayPal and I was one of the first
engineers and we worked on a number of
projects together at PayPal and same
thing I think one of the the ideas of
startups of successful startups is the
this idea of pivoting from what you were
originally starting to doing something
else instead and PayPal them you know
many people know what it is now many
people use it as a p2p payment service
or to business pay personal business
payment service but when it first
started it was this Palm Pilot security
application that you know one it's never
really got off the ground this is
security happened to these days I don't
know many people that still own carry
around Palm Pilots but the valuable
lesson there was just if you take a look
at what the users are doing what the
user feedback is and if people aren't
using it taking that technology and
maybe pivoting it towards something that
the users will use and we did that at
PayPal when we took the security side of
it and created a payment service on top
of it same thing at YouTube no in the
beginning it was not so in the the
relationship with MySpace started with
just the ability for myspace users to
embed HTML on to their profile pages and
YouTube had an HTML snippet that you
could copy and paste and put into your
myspace profile after a while it became
more of a formal relationship because so
many of their users were using YouTube
but it became almost a marriage that if
YouTube went down so much of the content
on MySpace would not be available to
view so we started actually formalizing
that relationship when we became we
became aware that so many of their users
depended on our service I think
especially early on in a startup and a
company when you have very limited
internal resources right I think some of
these partnerships especially early on
when you don't get a lot of these
invites a lot of people asking you to be
a partner you're getting easily excited
by it I do think that it's valuable to
not be overly aggressive in accepting
some of these partnerships so early on
at YouTube but
sort of an example this was a lot of
people asking us for white labeling the
product and just removing YouTube off
the label removing a sort of any
references at YouTube and they just
wanted us and they were paid they were
willing to pay hundreds of thousands of
dollars for this and at that time that
meant a lot for a YouTube but the end of
the day we always still hinged on the
fact that the brand name of YouTube was
very important to the product and it was
difficult I mean the earlier the company
I think the more resource star of the
company the harder it is to make that
decision but I do think that it's very
important to actually choose the right
partnerships that actually will help the
company in the long run rather than just
something in the next few months or next
few weeks I think that there are even a
few companies that wanted to put their
own video player on YouTube when I was
there we didn't allow it I think now
YouTube has accepted some of those deals
but I think it's a whole different world
by this point and some of these guys I
mean they just you know it's like ABC or
something and they they're just only one
unique creator of this content you
either do it their way or you'll never
get their content I I think it's
important to approach the question of
any kind of partnership or any kind of
agreement is looking at it from their
perspective what they benefit from a
deal in the making with you and I think
in the case of YouTube it was always the
same we didn't provide the revenue share
really we didn't do this sort of as
early on at least when we were there
prior to the acquisition by Google so
when we did these deals it was always
for marketing purposes it was always
yeah it's a prior to the acquisition of
Google there was still no sort of there
was not a lot of ads coming in so there
was not a lot of ad revenue so there was
not a lot of the sort of revenue share
that you see on YouTube so what can we
actually offer the content creators out
there it was really still for at that
time it was really still for short why
the content so things are 30 seconds to
two and a half minutes it wasn't for
long lengths in fact we had a rule that
no content could be longer than 10
minutes for the large chunk of the start
of YouTube and so it's for a short term
cash or Twain content so it wasn't for
you wouldn't upload an entire 30 minute
episode of The Daily Show or something
you wouldn't upload an entire two-hour
movie one we didn't allow it and two we
didn't want the platform to be seen is
that it was still four short pieces of
content that was uploading to the site
so when it came to actually working with
these content creators we branded
YouTube as a way to be able to market
your longer form content so it was just
maybe seen as a place a platform to show
movie trailers for your movie but you
wouldn't actually upload the entire
movie on to YouTube I think that's
gradually evolved and changed over a
period of time as higher form higher
quality content has become possible
bandwidth started getting cheaper people
are more accustomed to watching this
content on multiple devices now that
YouTube actually offers and caters to
watching the same content on multiple
devices at one time but at the time
during 2005 all the way throughout 2007
it was always for a short form of
content it wasn't the same quality and
it was a way to be able to get more
people that would have not heard your
music or would have not heard your movie
be able to use the two-minute link to be
able to showcase whatever it is that you
wanted to show